this is head hunters you know that duck
detective is really impressive why don't
they do a spin-off show you know it's
easier to see clues when you're closer
to the ground too much whimsy is so much
whimsy um
shows good but it's almost exhausting is
like so much stuff going on
in this one we have oh I should say uh
the code was he's still in the vents
which as I was going into this I was
like what does that mean like oh they
clearly show Larry King is still in the
vents
um so you were read how do you feel
about um all the celebrities are the
real celebrities even Sherlock Holmes
I'm amazed I guess right no that's John
Oliver um and they dug up Sir Arthur
Conan Doyle yes I love that they got
Larry King warms up out for anything but
that's great because he'll also take any
joke about him some sour Goblin or some
bad I decapitated Larry King he is he's
such a good sport
um cool he always in this only 112 you
have to be a good sport by that point uh
you know Coolio is in this which I am a
what's up with you yeah I met you they
just like try they just put a microphone
rather than like just followed around
hey get away from me what's up with that
oh and it's like boom you got your dog
finally so bad they just dangle the
joint in front of him and said here come
here save us it um so story's pretty
much uh they find this put away wax
museum of all these wax like replicas of
historical figures and such Coolio and
Larry King oh no Larry cheese kinda
historical figure
why are we so mean the Larry King we
should stop it um and pretty much they
bring them out because Mabel carts this
brand-new grunkle Stan wanna grow no
Stan loves turns out she's really good
at it too yeah one is both surprising
and not surprising yeah it's like
surprises wow that turned out really
good and it's not surprising cuz you're
like of course it is it's made yeah yeah
just
but the same time she'll want to make
was it a pretty princess pony princess
yeah a pretty princess on top of a
pretty princess pony yeah no I love the
fact that's like you smelled the way her
mind works yeah because it's not right a
scent or something like that it's like
it's a woman on top of a horse the hands
are a human hands but the feet are like
horse feed it's like sometimes like you
did would have come up with in toys yeah
um so uh that's great but uh grunkle
Stan's wax figure is murdered he's
beheaded and they're trying to find out
trying to solve this mystery and it
turns out it's actually the wax figures
they've come alive and they've won Oh
what's funny about it is when he found
for some that was a great line you know
wax Abraham Lincoln
you've been killed I'm looking at you
wax John Wilkes Booth but like Lizzie
Borden was next I was like I'll bet you
Lizzie Borden did it and that ends up
being kind of what happened what and
with the other wax figure boy Wow what I
love yeah and what I love about this is
that it's kind of a legit good mystery
because you know supernatural stuff can
happen uh but you don't know it's like
the major focus the whole time because
like the last one the monster was a
robot and stuff uh so you're cat
watching it's like well who did it and
you're kind of following and then it's
like the hole in the foot it's like
that's a really really good clue and it
makes perfect sense and when you start
to put you go like wait could it be the
wax figure it's like they come alive
just at the time when you realize
figured it out from the beginning oh did
you that I really had no fucking clue
and she actually even with the hole in
the foot I was still trying to find some
logic away and I'm just like I keep
forgetting sometimes it's like oh yeah
the wax figures can come to life I
should have just get but that's not like
going there in my head I'm like it's no
it's gotta be somebody real and then
when they came to life I'm like oh fuck
it's the perfect episode to do it with
because you don't quite have this
understanding that like anything can
happen quite yeah you know cuz like I
said it's just so the right balance
there um a few one of my favorite
running jokes starts here which is the
free pizza guy you know he shows up to
this thing wearing a free pizza shirt
and he always wears that shirt from this
point I got it every episode like we
doesn't feel like the S falling so that
it says yeah
that's the first hack yeah it's in the
opening but this is the first time like
in show you see the ass fall analysis in
other details I didn't notice till just
the beginning of this episode I noticed
that the the wind the woody colors the
wind vane yeah that's just what yeah now
that I can't believe you didn't know no
and your main credit informs it like
every single time I your eyes go to
what's largest on the screen and it's
you know the top of it I wasn't looking
at the letters and then in plus you take
things for granted you expect it to say
north south east west and a ZW it was
only when I just sort of stared down and
I saw the T there I'm like wait what
there's also a there's also a Bigfoot
for a frame when in the opening as well
and at the whole before it goes to black
the whole picture with the triangle in
the middle and all that I mean that you
can have a lot of fun with um but
that'll let you discover because not all
the answers are there for that one but
yeah so pretty much I'm trying to think
that the one other little Easter Egg
I've found that made me laugh a little
bit was that one of the people they were
looking for it's called Uncle Phil and I
don't know why they threw an Uncle Phil
in there but it's just it's one of the
people they're looking forward to yeah
maybe he just died around that point I
don't know how big the actor day I had
no idea but yeah so so that was kind of
funny um yeah John Oliver's great as uh
sure like a bit about the building slow
I begged the finalists
well done claps slowly sarcastically no
no that's too sincere slower yes
that's condescending nice and
condescending um and yeah again just
really some good jokes in this one uh
anytime it's it's funny cuz we always
make fun of Larry King but it's like
he's always great anytime he cameos on
anything I mean he's like always
hilarious he has a great rui an awful
human being he's killed ten people's
well I mean everyone knows that but you
know and eight them so he could stay
alive I mean that's the way to do it but
again we just going right back to making
fun of him what has he ever done to like
anybody
he likes a lot of really bad movies he
doesn't his sure he doesn't know himself
out whenever I see you no no J greatest
moment reader huh one of the greatest
movies of the year Larry King I'm like
oh this is gonna suck
transformers 12 um yeah that's going to
um hard for that I have nothing personal
against him he may have been responsible
for the Holocaust I don't know maybe I
mean allies old enough to event response
um it does make me what I love to see
him like just in the middle of an
episode like they're having a bow or
something like that just suddenly he
comes back out of the bed don't like
bite some wonder said yeah see I'm
wondering how many of these jokes are
gonna come back cuz it says I love him
do um I would like to see that again -
I'd like to see that head come out I'd
like to see the gnomes my goal is I
think I'm gonna mention the gnomes and
everyone I was just knows of you until I
come back
elms again and you're gonna be so
disappointed that's a fine thing when
they come back it's like it's funny but
it's like four away oh but um yeah so
it's a try think what else it was all I
know is the more we're talking here the
less gravity falls I'm seeing that is
true we're just stuck on the first frame
of the episode so yeah and I'm curious
what's gonna happen with this bird on
the pine tree stuck mid-flight yeah yeah
I guess we'll never know is he is he
gonna make it or is he gonna fall to his
death until the next episode make it
show